alaric michelle hasn't seen his father
in three years in terms of communication
i think what's what's horrible right you
only have two parents in your life
um i thankfully have two amazing parents
um now when one is taken away from you
it's it's tough to deal with
specifically at a young age his father
is christian michelle
a british businessman based in dubai
since december 2018 he's been in prison
in india jailed over his alleged
involvement in a defense scandal
mr michelle claims he is victim to a de
facto prisoner swap
with princess latifa the daughter of
dubai's ruler
she was caught in indian waters while
trying to leave her family
an event happened in the indian ocean
which completely changed my life
and the proceedings that i was under mr
michelle
maintains he is innocent and was
acquitted in previous trials
his prisoner swap claims have been
recognized by the un
who say they note it with concern and
that his story has not been disputed
by either the uae or india
speaking publicly for the first time his
son
says the un's comments have brought hope
i think it's good that we're we're
finally having the vocal and
physical support of the un um which is
obviously something we need because if
if you have the un's back and then
clearly
there is something that's going wrong
and it's not on our end
one of mr michelle's lawyers told sky
news he wants to see
more action from the british government
i've met
with representatives from the foreign
office to to raise this case
as a case of significance and they are
of course in contact
with the indian authorities but they
need to do a lot more
india has rejected the working group's
findings saying they have a robust
legal system and have followed all due
process
including during his extradition arrest
and subsequent custody they also
highlight that the un working group's
decisions
are not legally binding the uae
embassy did not respond to our requests
for comment
while a uk foreign office spokesperson
said staff
are supporting mr michelle and regularly
raise his case with the indian
authorities
videos published by sky news revealed
what princess latifah
claimed happened to her after she was
stopped by indian forces
in what her family say was a rescue
mission i'm in
a villa i'm a hostage and
this villa has been converted into a
jail all the windows are borrowed shut i
can't open any window
mr michelle sits in prison turning over
how the capture of a princess
he's never met may have cost him his
freedom
samuel burgess sky news